welcome back to new rockstars I'm marina
masterís Star Wars Episode nine the rise
of Skywalker promised us to solve the
lingering mystery of Rey's true origin
in the last Jedi kylo tells Rey that her
parents are nobodies but that doesn't
necessarily mean that what he said is
true he could have of course been lying
and maybe for good reason
here's a nice spot for us boiler warning
in case my ridiculous theory ends up
somehow being true I made a bet with
Erik and he's gonna pay my rent if I'm
right here we go okay it's been said
that their location of the final scene
in Rises Skywalker will melt your brain
what if it's so mind-melting because
it's actually a location from the
original trilogy and what if it's not
just the same place but also the same
time
Kapali my bone okay stay with me here we
know that one of the top priorities for
JJ Abrams has to be tying up loose
threads from the prequels like what the
hell is a trade federation battleship
doing in this new film huh what another
priority for JJ is dumping aspects of
the prequels that fans didn't really
like like Jar Jar Binks I'm gonna
explore the theory that the mystery of
Rey will connect directly to one of the
biggest enigmas of the Star Wars
universe the birth of Anakin Skywalker
and the Anakin's mother Shmi and Ray are
actually the same person
techadon in my people [ __ ] but it's most
definitely a connection okay so in order
for Shmi and raids to be the same person
a little something called time travel
has to exist in the Star Wars universe
the good thing is it actually does time
travel was introduced in the animated
series Star Wars rebels when ezra
bridger a force sensitive character goes
through a world between worlds this
other realm allows ezra to move outside
of space and time and he arrives at a
Jedi Temple in the past once there he
rescues ahsoka tano from a battle with
Darth Vader later they find another
portal that leads to Emperor Palpatine
now
Palpatine can't pass through this other
dimension himself but he can see where
it ends and attacks
Ezra an ahsoka with SIF lightning
through the dimension so even if he
can't use it at the time Emperor
Palpatine is definitely aware that time
travel exists why does this matter for
this insane conspiracy well according to
Canon Anakin Skywalker was conceived
when Palpatine manipulated the forest
to conceive a child in Schmid's womb
which is pretty gross and weird in
Episode three Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine tells Anakin about the
legendary Darth Plagueis the wise assist
Lord so powerful he could manipulate
midi-chlorians to prevent death and more
notably create life it is later revealed
in books that Palpatine was The
Apprentice who killed Plagueis so
presumably he also knows how to create
life with midi-chlorians then he uses it
to you know be gross and weird okay cut
back to now we have three rise of
Skywalker trailers to go off of
and from these it's clear that Palpatine
wants rey for some dark important
purpose
this conspiracy theory hinges on the
idea that Palpatine's plan for Rey is to
close the time loop that fulfills his
own destiny his vast evil wisdom from
life and the force means that he knows
one day he will be destined to find a
young force-sensitive woman bring her
back in time using the Jedi Temple
portal he witnessed in Star Wars rebels
and then use that power to manipulate
midi-chlorians and create life in her
womb being super creepy and Palpatine
had to wait to pull this time-travel
impregnation force stunt until after ray
had some meaningful education from a
certain Jedi Master Luke Skywalker
because by then she has a more balanced
view of the force this means that when
himuro's rey on Tatooine 75 years
earlier she would be more accepting of
qui-gon jinn training her son because he
shares her perspectives around the Jedi
that includes some gray areas
neither of them think the Jedi are a
hundred percent purely good or that the
people on the dark side have always been
a hundred percent bad okay that's one
option or Palpatine just wiped Rey's
memory when he shoved her through the
time portal that would make all of this
a lot simpler
look storytelling that involves time
travel is always a little bit of a
mindful in order for this theory to work
we have to be in a world where time
travel functions as a closed loop in
other words even though you may have
used time travel to alter the future or
the past once it occurs you've basically
final destination yourself the same
events happened over and over no matter
how many times you fast-forward or
rewind a tape this is the opposite of
movies where time travel triggers a
completely new and separate timeline
like in avengers endgame or back to the
future
nobody's disappearing out of pictures
are trying not to bang their mom in Star
Wars although siblings have been known
to make out a little bit mmm weird
anyway Palpatine discovers rey takes her
back in time uses medic lawrence to make
carl prego and then leaves her alone on
Tatooine to raise a young anakin
skywalker
his future key to taking control of the
galaxy boom Shmi is rape rate is SH week
and of course Rey later dies after being
kidnapped and beaten by the Tusken
Raiders admittedly this theory is kind
of sad and really dark but it also makes
Rey pretty much the most important
character of the Star Wars universe and
hey she has some good times right she
had a good run thanks for coming with me
this wild ride and of course this is all
just but if it turns out to be true Eric
is gonna be riding my rent check come
January what do you think rates fate
will be in the rise of Skywalker comment
down below with your thoughts and
subscribe to new rock stars for more
crackpot conspiracy theories all about
the nerd stuff you love thanks for
joining me
above ie Eric owes me money
[Laughter]
[Music]